it's usually a nogo area for police but
now people living in the gang stronghold
of soya Pango outside El Salvador's
Capital as sealed in
security forces are preparing to go door
to door rounding up gang members but
police say ordinary members of the
public shouldn't be afraid consisting
we are extracting all criminals who may
be hiding here in the municipality of
soya Pango we are here to guarantee the
security of the honest hard-working
population
close to 60 000 people have been
arrested since president naive bukheli
declared a state of emergency in March
but rightscript accused the government
of being heavy-handed activists say
young men are being wrongly targeted for
how they look and for living in
gang-controlled slums the government
denies this
we have been planning this military
Siege very
carefullyapango to affect the honest
population as little as possible there
are 40 strategic points where we are
working to arrest gang members who are
in the communities according to
intelligence information president
bucale's state of emergency grants
police powers to make arrests without
due process and the recent survey found
that 75 percent of Salvadorans approve
of the Hardline measures
gangs effectively controlled vast ways
of territory and extorted money from
businesses in the run-up to the state of
emergency dozens of people were killed
in a single weekend of gang violence
but activists sworn innocent people are
being caught up in the mass arrests and
not receiving basic legal rights Barbara
angopa Al Jazeera